um you have to shu you have to win
it's a cut throat thing
do not be nice be funny
be merciless be brutal
don't let them win the crowd over you
are you done
um uh don't let them speak unless you
feel like they're going to hang
themselves and you're confident you can
you can beat it shut them down
don't let them know you're encouraging
it um
hopefully you embarrass them into
silence uh
if they do start to win get mean
get mean if they start to win meaning if
the crowd is laughing
at what they're saying more than what
you're saying
don't get flustered and walk off stage
if they're burning down the show you
burn it down even more
because the set is done anyway so i
don't
i don't mean yeah i just don't
don't be scared don't look weak
just burn it down let the crowd know
that
they ruined it get get meaner
um and just stay in the pocket do not
do not go like uh stutter your words and
like walk off and let them win you can't
it's a it's a real knife fight at that
point
and you gotta you know you don't want to
you're not playing ufc where there's
rules it's a street knife fight
and you don't want them to win and if
they do
burn it down because they already burnt
it down by making the crowd laugh so
it's over anyway
so figure out a way to burn it down more
than they burnt it down for you
so don't start mean just start a little
conversational
and speaking with them i think malcolm x
in this situation
by any means necessary win that you have
to
you have to win that now examples
there's
too many for me to think of um
it happens all the time it's something
comics got to deal with and uh
you should have a bag of tricks you
should have some go-to
uh cuts some digs um
and what i mean by be mean is like don't
go like personal
i'm just saying mean jokes like if you
have some mean ones
you know it's like i've seen i've seen
jim gaffigan get mean i've seen gary
goldman get mean
i've you know you know you just yeah
in fact they get the meanest because
they require the most attention
and silence and orderly crap so
um you can't let a heckler
steal the limelight and you can't let
them win
if they ruin the show by saying
something funnier than you in the crowds
likes it
you got no choice but to burn the whole
thing down you know what i mean it's
like you can't give them that house
either it's your house or it's nobody's
house it's not gonna be his house
so that's my advice burn it down so if
you like ended a show on a heckler you
just freak out on them and then just
leave
i make the crowd go ooh if they get
funny and say something funny
um that beats me which has very rarely
happened
i'm good with heckler i'd say you know
some people are better at it
i'm kind of good in the fly train
yourself to be good in the fly have some
stock
it's good to have some stock responses
if you need that
um but if i've gotten the times that
i've like gotten beaten yeah i just kind
of uh
i just kind of burned the rest of the
set down and and just
in other words i didn't go back to my
jokes i guess that's what i'm trying to
say
the set is over like if they start
getting laughs
and the crowd gets behind them keep
going at them
you have the microphone so you can
always be louder
so don't go back into your set it's over
the crowd likes them it's a nowaday
the person has you've lost so now you
have to burn it down you have to make
the crowd
pay the crowd side with them so the
crowd them
everybody you're leaving guns
blazing
and you're going out cutting him off
don't let him speak when he starts
speaking you cut him off
you tell him this sucks you tell him the
room saw you tell him you
that's what i mean by burn it down like
you guys suck you don't deserve it
blah blah blah this guy try to
think of something mean
do a lot because you're louder than him
one of them will hit
you know he's speaking they can't hear
him so you just go you're a
idiot look at those jeans look at you
look you're probably one of those people
don't pause burn it down
that's what i that's what i meant i
guess that's uh i wasn't being
specific on what you do that's what you
do that's the most impact
you've gotten in this interview is
talking about hecklers you're like you
gotta yeah because they suck
they think they're helping a show
i mean you know you don't get beat by a
hacker where he gets the crowd laughing
then you go
hahaha yeah man that was a good one all
right anyway so let me get back to the
material
um you know no the crowd they don't
they're not into it anymore
yep he's he's emboldened and you look
weak can't let that happen
yeah that's um robin said yes robin
posted in our facebook group a video of
rocky dale davis
recently dealing with a heckler very
well if um
anybody watching this is curious about
that um yeah but uh
don't start mean start start trying to
you know be funny try to be funny and
deal with your funny and shut him up
get the crowd laughing and uh hopefully
you embarrass him into silence which is
often what happens
yeah because the crowd is on your side
like they want you to win but if the
heckler starts
then that becomes a game if if you don't
just extinguish it quickly it can it can
escalate quickly you want to extinguish
it quickly it is a threat
it is a threat to your show it's a
threat to everything
if they're talking and not heckling if
they're disruptive
ask to have them removed you know that's
another thing that's what i mean by
burning it down like
you know don't go haha that was a good
one don't agree with the crowd if they
you know it's like you can do like a
smirk and then be like okay now you got
to leave now because you're disruptive
like don't let the heckler be funnier
than you
at all costs you have to be a heartless
stone-cold killer to
stamp out that threat if you love comedy
as much as we do here at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips